[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on what's going on Woody hey can
you hear me we got you what's up Woody
I'm on a I'm on a flip phone I'm
oldfashioned we're oldfashioned too
perfect what's up man okay uh yeah uh my
girlfriend's having uh well I found out
a well I think I lost still there go
sorry that was on me sorry about that
Woody okay okay get okay uh so she's
getting a heart transplant and then I
found out she's getting a kidney
transplant she has yeah she's on the
she's on the list and they're looking
for one right now wow that's a that's a
fullon that's like a a new body yeah
that's a chip and Joanna makeover that's
all the way to the studs man what H
what's going on yeah and so uh and that
then at St Thomas is where they going to
do this okay uh and I mean they're
looking for they're looking uh right now
and it could happen at any time I guess
and it might not but you don't you just
don't know but anyway uh the question is
am I responsible for her medical
bills this is the
concern well I well let me tell you in
life work and family work comes first
family comes second
and why that is if you ain't got no
money the family's going to leave anyway
wait a minute no I think you got that
backwards brother but no no no no well
when you under the bridge down there and
they say daddy what's going
on who said Daddy what's going
on Woody Woody pull back hold back hold
back for a second hold up hold up thank
you um it's interesting to me that this
your girlfriend how long has she been
your girlfriend number one please say
six weeks
please 20 years 20 20
years yeah Woody why haven't you married
her
yet uh I'm Catholic
what I don't even know what that even
more reason to marry her cuz I know
y'all living together y yeah well you
were some help be I no no uh uh I've
been married one time she been married
one time and we just rather not woody
you've been married for 20 years to this
woman right you can pretend all you want
and play whatever semantic games but
you've been as married as as any other
married folks have been that's right
everybody thinks that everybody says
that they keep calling my wife I said
she's not my wife yes she she is more
your wife why why do you feel that way
I'm trying to understand why you feel
that way why you don't want to go all
the way take it to the Limit you ever
heard the song The warer yes yes that's
me you hey Woody you watch you watch too
much Yellowstone as what you do woody is
a rolling stone guys all right so hey
Woody that is your like Woody she's your
wife and you can call her whatever you
want to she's your wife yeah um let me
ask you this let me ask you this and
this is all
seriousness okay if I had a friend I'm
thinking of I have a particular friend
in my mind just a friend a buddy of mine
okay a guy that I grew up with if that
dude lived with me for 20 years was just
my my my ride or die friend and he had
to go to the hospital and have just a
complete transmission change right yeah
I would I I not obligation but as my
brother I would participate in helping
where I could I I'm I'm struck by your
question yeah cuz she is your wife you
can call it what you want she's your
wife you've been together for 20 years
living together
yeah do you not want to pay you don't
want to help like what's what's the
where's what's the root of the question
well the trouble is the money the
money's not there well does she then
what then why ask the question it don't
matter what you're obligated if you
don't got it you don't got it I mean she
has
Insurance yeah she got the uh human and
Medicare whatever and so do we know have
you guys talked with them to know okay
what is this going to cost like what's
your out of-pocket maximum is she doing
stuff that is above and beyond her
coverage do you guys know what that is
because those are real questions I do
want you to ask uh we're not going to
aim
NY she know she wants to why we're
trying to well because we want her to
have the heart and the kidney well yes
the money don't mean nothing it does it
know it does mean something Woody I'm G
challenge you on that because she she
has Insurance all you need to do is call
him up today and say hey my girlfriend
is having this procedure comlaw wife um
you know as as far as we know like she's
going to the doctors and stuff that
she's supposed to do what's our per year
what's the maximum we're going to pay
per year because this is going to be
some ongoing treatment what's the
maximum we pay per year and they might
say something like $7,000 or $4,000 or
$10,000 but knowing is good then my next
question is has she been working does
she have any money
anywhere that's that's where I come in
at okay so your money
bags I'm I provide her a roof and food
a roof and food okay yeah I mean it's uh
when when I found out that she was sick
actually we had we was getting ready to
part part ways kind of Butz I I travel a
lot and you know we get along great and
she watched the house for me make sure
nobody don't steal nothing you know what
I'm saying Andy you're describing you're
describing my dog Rose and this is not
the first time y'all have tried to part
ways let's be honest about that you keep
ending up together my country dog
watches the house while we're gone yeah
yeah well she been she's had a rough a
rough I say a rough life and it just
she's been with you for 25 to 30% of it
I know it and it
just hey do you love her do you love her
or are you just with her out of
convenience and out of I'm comfortable
it's both it's both I guess hey let me
ask you
just just just guy to guy nobody's
listening to us except for a couple
million people yeah what what are you
afraid of Are You Afraid about you lose
the person that you
love uh
both no I want you to be honest and
we've been climbing around I want you to
be honest are you terrified that you're
about to lose your best friend and oh oh
No Doubt no doubt okay I mean you we've
been you know we've been through several
things both of us our prach and it just
uh and I know how this world works well
none of us get out of it alive the
lawyers don't care no I hey're we're not
passing none of this crap off to the
lawyers this is about you being my
brother one state over a grown man not
putting your head in the sand when
something scary is coming up up against
the woman you love you're going to do
what Jade said want you call the
hospital get some numbers on this thing
it's not about am I responsible for her
bills the woman I love might die I'm
going to do what I can and she's not a
pet she's not body watches the house
she's the woman of the last quarter
Century of your life let's see what we
can do with some real numbers and some
real action and let's support that woman
we'll be right back create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life